herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
es ist ein denkwürdiger tag für das
berchtesgadener land so der landrat des
landkreises vor etwa einer stunde in
einer pressekonferenz
der grund das berchtesgadener land hat
einen traurigen rekord heute zu
verzeichnen in der korona pandemie
nämlich 272 so hoch ist die zahl der die
sieben tages ins ident und das heißt
hier ist das berchtesgadener land mit
dem watzmann mit touristischen
sehenswürdigkeiten mit dem schönen
königssee ist auf einmal an der spitze
der korona neuinfektionen und das hat
zur folge dass der landkreis drastische
die drastischen maßnahmen getroffen
hatte die es bisher in deutschland gibt
ausgangs beschränkungen so wie es sie
seit monaten nicht gegeben hat schulen
müssen schließen krankenhäuser können
nicht besucht werden und jeder soll
weitestgehend zu hause bleiben und nur
mit besonderen gründen zum beispiel wenn
es zum zur arbeit geht oder zum
supermarkt kann man das haus verlassen
sonst nicht wir wollen mit unserem
reporter vor ort sprechen alexander pohl
ist in berchtesgaden alexander wie sehen
die maßnahmen denn aus sind drastische
maßnahmen wie sie es richtigerweise
gesagt haben das ist auch interessant
werden jetzt kurz vor unserem gespräch
hier noch einmal ein gespräch unter
leuten hier in berchtesgaden mitbekommen
wo der eine oder andere gefragt hast du
schon was gehört was gilt denn jetzt
eigentlich und ab wann gilt ist man kann
sehen dass die menschen hier selber noch
nicht so genau wissen was ist eigentlich
für maßnahmen gibt und wie ist sie
betrifft
es geht im konkreten darum dass morgen
ab 14 uhr niemand mehr ohne einen
triftigen grund sein haus oder seine
wohnung verlassen darf zu einem
triftigen grund keinen arztbesuch
gehören etwa oder auch der tägliche
einkauf natürlich das ist erlaubt dazu
gehört dass kitas schließen dass schulen
schließen was eine enorme eingriff
natürlich in das leben der
der familien ist restaurants müssen
schließen kneipen müssen schließen
restaurants dürfen bis 20 juli noch
einen turbo betrieb haben aber ob das
tatsächlich den wirten etwas nützt das
sage ich jetzt mal zu bezweifeln
also alles in allem muss man schon sagen
sind dass die drastischen maßnahmen seit
dem frühjahr seit dem ersten lockdown
vergeben hat oder eigentlich haben die
menschen hier schon gehofft dass sie von
sowas nochmal verschont werden die
stimmung war ja auch sehr gedämpft sehr
nachdenklich der landrat aber auch sehr
nachdenkliche worte hat die
staatsministerin für landwirtschaft
michaela kaniber gefunden keine wünscht
sich einen lockt dann umso wichtiger ist
es jetzt auf diese ausgangs beschränkung
auch zu schauen sich die maßnahmen zu
herzen zu nehmen und dass wir als
gesellschaft zusammenhalten und meine
große bitte ist in der tat auch an die
nachbarlandkreise aber eben auch an das
nachbarland österreich hier rücksicht zu
nehmen
das ist ja nun ein sehr deutlicher
appell fragen wir nochmal alexander pohl
wir haben denn die menschen das ganze
aufgenommen bleiben sie zu hause
wir bitten um verständnis aber es muss
so drastisch sein
was haben die menschen denn schon den
tag über zu ihnen gesagt denn der
ministerpräsident müller hat ja quasi
eine art lockdown bereits am mittag
angekündigt genau das hat er getan dass
ein locker und angekündigt und wenn man
jetzt hier den halben tag über sage ich
mit den menschen gesprochen hat dann
kann man schon sagen das gefühl was ihr
am meisten vorherrscht ist schon
verständnis also die leute haben
verständnis dafür dass die maßnahmen
noch einmal verschärft werden sie sagen
na gut wenn die zahlen hoch gehen dann
muss das wohl sein was man aber auch
immer wieder hört ist das ja warum
halten sich denn eigentlich die leute
nicht dran also man kann von sehr vielen
hier unverständnis darüber hören dass
sich bestimmte gruppen eben einfach
nicht an die maßnahmen halten nicht an
das masken tragen halten dass bestimmte
gruppen nach wie vor partys feiern da
herrscht hier ein großes unverständnis
vor verständnis wiederum für die
maßnahmen für schärfere maßnahmen muss
man muss allerdings jetzt auch sagen
das ist jetzt so kommt die ist jetzt
gekommen ist das hätten vielleicht die
wenigsten erwartet also ein kompletter
lockdown und da ist es schon so dass man
sich in seinem täglichen leben natürlich
eingeschränkt fühlt was man hier auch
spüren kann ist ein bisschen resignation
so nach dem motto näher was sollen wir
denn machen
offensichtlich gibt es keine andere
möglichkeit
was wir nur sehr wenig hier vernommen
haben ist absolutes unverständnis oder
menschen die gesagt haben
das braucht es doch gar nicht und das
ist alles übertrieben das waren
vielleicht ein zwei die das in diese
richtung geäußert haben aber ich würde
sagen bei den meisten menschen herrscht
doch verständnis vor bei vielen sagen
wir auch gastwirten oder auch
ladenbesitzern kommt natürlich auch die
existenzangst dazu die existenzangst das
ist wäre jetzt genau meine frage gewesen
wir haben die im einspieler ja auch die
herrlichen bilder gesehen der watzmann
der königssee da ist das garten dass der
ganze landkreis ist natürlich ein
tourismusgebiet wenn jetzt hotels
schließen müssen denn gasthäuser
schließen müssen cafés schließen müssen
wir haben gründe um auch keiner mehr hin
reisen soll keiner ausreisen soll was
bedeutet das für den landkreis für die
wirtschaft die vom tourismus abhängt ja
das natürlich ein herber schlag und man
kann das vielleicht hinter mir sehen
diese diese ladenzeile die sie hier
sehen ja das sind alles leben die
natürlich sehr stark auch vom tourismus
abhängigen wir haben vorhin mit jemandem
gesprochen
der sagte na ja den ersten lockdown also
den im frühjahr den habe ich noch
wegstecken können aber was natürlich
jetzt passiert wenn es zu einem das ist
ja de facto jetzt ein zweiter lockdown
das kann man nicht so genau sagen die
rücklagen die rücklagen sind irgendwann
aufgebraucht also keiner von denen auch
von den ladenbesitzern mit dem wir
gesprochen haben war jetzt in einer
extrem pessimistischen stimmung da
gesagt wir schaffen das alles nicht aber
die die sorge darüber dass das eigene
geschäft nicht mehr läuft dass der
umsatz weg bleibt das natürlich die
rücklagen irgendwann aufgebraucht sind
und das muss ich auch sagen dass man
auch auf den staat schon hofft das
hilfsprogramm was es beim ersten
lockdown lockdown gab das sowas
natürlich wiederholt wird dass die
politik natürlich jetzt auch maßnahmen
ergreift um den läden um der wirtschaft
insgesamt hier zu helfen also diese
erwartungen die konnte man hier schon
sehr deutlich spüren vielen dank für
diesen eindruck
dieses stimmungsbild aus berchtesgaden
alexander vielen vielen dank
das berchtesgadener land der landkreis
ist an der spitze was die neuinfektionen
angeht aber ein ganz deutschland steigen
die neue infektionszahlen der überblick
was die sieben tages incidents angeht
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
wurden täglich 6050 kroner neuer
ansteckungen registriert
gestern lag der wert bei 5.890
bundesweit liegen nun 119 städte und
landkreise über 50 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in einer woche
besonders stark betroffen der landkreis
berchtesgadener land
wir bekommen
zuschriften und fragen florian behrens
schreibt und fragt über facebook wie
viele menschen befinden sich in dem
krankenhaus also dort im berchtesgadener
land wir haben der pressekonferenz
intensiv zugehört keine konkreten zahlen
wurden genannt aber der landrat hat sehr
deutlich gemacht wie schwer man es sich
getan gemacht hat eine solch drastische
entscheidung zu treffen und dass man mit
den krankenhäusern in der umgebung
gesprochen hat und gemeinsam beraten hat
ob es diese drastischen schritte geben
muss und die krankenhäuser werden wohl
entsprechend auch die zustimmung gegeben
haben beziehungsweise den rat gegeben
haben weil die infektionsketten nicht
mehr zu kappen sind weil einfach die
infektionen aus dem ruder laufen die
wege nicht nach gefolgt werden können
in den kliniken im berchtesgadener land
werden 13 cupid 19 patienten aus dem
landkreis derzeit stationär behandelt
das ist die neueste informationen die
wir haben
derzeit werden allerdings keine
patienten intensivmedizinisch betreut
aber trotzdem eben ein anlass dass die
krankenhäuser gesagt haben drastische
maßnahmen klare maßnahmen wären
notwendig reden wir mit einem virologen
mit einem experten dr martin stürmer ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich sind all diese
drastischen maßnahmen die der landkreis
berchtesgadener land jetzt getroffen
haben so notwendig
ja es sind schon sehr heftige maßnahmen
das haben wir ja in deutschland bis dato
noch in keinem der kreise betroffene
kreise gesehen und spricht schon dafür
dass man da wirklich eine sehr ernste
situation vorfinden und letztendlich
versucht man weil man die
infektionsketten nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kann einfach dem virus
seine grundlage zu erziehen entziehen
nämlich die kontaktmöglichkeiten uns ist
allen klar
eine solche erkrankung braucht ein
mensch zu mensch kontakt bzw eine eine
nähe von zwei oder mehreren menschen um
sich zu übertragen und die weniger
kontakte man zulässt umso eher kann sich
das virus eben nicht mehr ausbreiten und
gerade in der situation in der sich der
kreis aktuell befindet scheint es
tatsächlich die einzige vernünftige und
richtige maßnahme zu sein
er stellt sich automatisch ein bisschen
die frage ob wir alle in richtung
berchtesgaden gehen weil überall in
deutschland die infektionszahlen steigen
drastische maßnahmen dort heute die
frage ist ein bisschen droht uns das
alles hat am mittwoch ja die konferenz
gegeben zwischen kanzlerin merkel und
den ministerpräsidenten die maßnahmen
die dort verabschiedet worden sind
wollen wir uns jetzt nochmal im
überblick anschauen und dann vergleichen
die strenge sind maßnahmen einige gelten
schon bei 35 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohnern wo so viele fälle gibt greift
eine ergänzende masken pflicht maske auf
wo menschen dicht zusammen kommen das
könnten fußgängerzonen sein und private
feiern werden begrenzt auf 25 teilnehmer
im öffentlichen raum im privaten auf 15
wo noch mehr neue infektionen auftreten
50 pro 100000 einwohner dürfen nur noch
zehn personen zusammen feiern zu hause
maximal zwei ausstände für treffen
allgemein zugelassen in der
öffentlichkeit nur bis zu zehn auf
veranstaltungen höchstens 100 personen
mehr nur mit genehmigten konzept
und die gastronomie hat eine sperrstunde
23 uhr neue ansteckungen neue regeln und
ein appell vom bund jeder soll reisen in
und aus hotspots unterlassen da fragen
wir einfach noch mal den theologen
martin stürmer wenn wir jetzt diese
maßnahme vergleichen da gab es ja auch
schon wieder schritte die zurückgenommen
worden sind beherbergungs verbot ist
gekippt worden gerichte haben gesagt
sperrstunde geht auch nicht wirte haben
geklagt also sind ja ziemlich wässrige
sachen gewesen was in berchtesgaden
heute beschlossen worden ist richtig
konkrete ausgangs beschränkungen richtig
zu hause bleiben schulen kitas werden
geschlossen ist ja eine ganz andere
qualität wie sehen sie das
definitiv ist das eine andere qualität
wenn wir uns dem beschlossenen maßnahmen
katalog mal zu wenden
dann habe ich schon gesehen dass vieles
teilweise einkassiert worden ist von
gerichten insofern wird da der
infektionsschutz und das allgemeine
recht doch eben anders gewichtet und man
muss natürlich auch folgendes sehen wenn
ich zum beispiel eine sperrstunde
einführen wenn ich im öffentlichen raum
nicht einschränke und vieles in den
privaten bereich ab wandert habe ich
noch mehr schwierigkeiten das ganze zu
kontrollieren und dränge letztendlich
vieles in eine grauzone die der staat
gar nicht mehr überwachen kann und der
appell an die freiwilligkeit von frau
merkel war letztendlich auch ein
ausdruck dessen dass man wohl befürchtet
in vielen bereichen nicht mehr
kontrollieren zu können
mit den jetzt in berchtesgaden
besprochen der beschlossenen maßnahmen
hat man eben eine andere schärfe
erreicht in dem man tatsächlich eine
deutliche bessere kontrolle wieder über
die kontakte der menschen hat und
weniger mehr auch nicht mehr auf die
freiwilligkeit setzt sondern eben
tatsächlich durch ganz rigorose
maßnahmen versucht die infektionszahlen
wieder unter kontrolle zu bringen
angela merkel die kanzlerin hat ja nach
dem gespräch nach der konferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten noch mal einen
eindringlichen appell an die bürger
abgegeben und gesagt bleiben sie zu
hause wie würden sie das denn jetzt
interpretieren zu hause bleiben so
ungefähr wie jetzt in berchtesgaden man
hat überhaupt keine kontakte mehr
betritt gar nicht mehr die straße
verlässt nicht das haus oder wie würden
sie sagen wie weit muss man da gehen
ja tatsächlich denke ich dass frau
merkel das nicht in der form gemeint hat
wie es jetzt in berchtesgaden umgesetzt
wird weil der kreis hat natürlich eine
infektionsgeschehen aber es ist doch
deutlich höher ist als das was in vielen
anderen regionen stattfindet was nicht
heißt dass die anderen regionen auch
nicht noch hinkommen können
nein ich denke man sollte wirklich bei
jeder aktion bei jeder aktivität die man
selber unternehmen möchte die man plant
sich wirklich kritisch hinterfragen ob
diese notwendig ist ich bin nicht ein
freund davon das private leben und das
öffentliche leben jetzt wieder auf null
zu reduzieren
ich finde es aber gut wenn dann
tatsächlich in sich geht und wieder ein
bisschen in eine gewisse entschleunigung
kommt und wirklich ein bisschen den fuß
vom gas nimmt auf die bremse stellt und
gerade die menschen die doch gerne viel
feiern sich doch auch mal hinterfragen
ob das jetzt aktuell noch der richtige
zeitpunkt ist viel zu feiern weil wir
haben ja auch eine verantwortung auch
gerade unseren älteren mitbürgern
gegenüber
die zunächst von der infektion verschont
bleiben sollen
weil sonst sehen wir in den
krankenhäusern deutlich mehr fälle
intensiv fälle und werden auch deutlich
mehr todesfälle sehen und das gilt es zu
vermeiden
jetzt hat es ja bereits viele appelle
gegeben
die zahlen sind trotzdem gestiegen dass
er trotzdem feiern gegeben es gibt auch
leute die geheime partys dann machen
also sich über alle regeln hinwegsetzen
würden sie aber sagen dass so etwas wie
jetzt berchtesgaden erlebt einen yard
lockdown einer eine ausgangs
beschränkung dass das vielleicht
wachrüttelt meinen sie das wird jetzt
vielleicht wachrütteln und viele dinge
ändern
ja es haben schon so oft diskutiert
welche möglichkeiten hat man dann diese
maßnahmen für alle begreiflich zu machen
wie wichtig ist es sich daran zu halten
und klar sowas ist natürlich auch um wo
ein signal holla guck mal was da
passiert das kann uns in unserem kreis
auch passieren und das ist eigentlich
das was wir gar nicht wollen
insofern ist natürlich auch eine gewisse
hoffnung da dass das eine signalwirkung
auch für andere menschen andere menschen
wieder hat zu sagen das möchten wir
gerne vermeiden
eigentlich sicher bin ich mir noch nicht
ob das wirklich so wirkt und was die
andere sache angeht wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich erst mal noch ein paar tage
warten bis die maßnahmen beschlossen
worden sind auch wirklich sich in den
zahlen widerspiegeln
weil all das was wir jetzt an
infektionsgeschehen sehen ist ja
mindestens immer fünf bis sieben tage
wenn nicht sogar wochen zurückliegen und
insofern muss man schauen ob die zahlen
sich wirklich zurückentwickeln mit den
beschlossenen maßnahmen
ansonsten befürchte ich tatsächlich dass
wir auch in anderen städten und kreisen
solche rigorosen maßnahmen sehen werden
er komme mal auf maßnahmen wie schwierig
das ist auch mit seinen mitbürgern das
umzusetzen andrea wilkes salome schreibt
wie muss denn ein großraumbüro mit circa
25 leuten gelüftet werden niemand mag
ein fenster aufmachen wenn man es dann
auf macht dann wird man auf einmal
angemeckert schreibt sie also sozusagen
dafür kritisiert also allein ja im
privaten bereich oder bei der arbeit
solche tipps und regeln umzusetzen
scheint ja schwierig zu sein
ja absolut das ist ja das was wir glaube
ich alltäglich oder jeder von uns auch
schon schon erlebt hat und es geht ja
schon mit den schulen los jede schule
hat andere möglichkeiten eben
entsprechend fenster aufzuweisen zu
lüften in den privatbereich in den
restaurants in den büros lüften alleine
würde schon viel helfen aber es ist
tatsächlich in der realität umzusetzen
das sehen wir ja mit den schwierigkeiten
die da verbunden sind und wir haben es
ja auch im sommer hat nie geschafft die
infektionszahlen wirklich auf auf nahezu
null runter zu setzen weil es eben sehr
sehr schwierig ist eben alle
möglichkeiten auszunutzen für das virus
eben doch sich zu übertragen und wir
werden das auch jetzt im winter nicht
schaffen das zu 100% zu generieren nur
die zahlen die wir jetzt am anfang des
herbstes schon sehen
die sind doch schon ziemlich hoch und
der tendenz war auch ziemlich
erschreckend wie schnell das ganze
gestiegen und da muss man halt eben das
bestmögliche tun und ich hoffe dass auch
solche sachen wie dass man an gemacht
wird wenn man plötzlich das fenster
aufmacht um vernünftig zu lüften
dass das bald auch der vergangenheit
wieder angehört dass jeder versteht wie
ernst die lage ist und wie wichtig es
ist eben die maßnahme umzusetzen und
gutes lüften gehört definitiv dazu
ich greife jetzt mal auf was unser
reporter so ein bisschen sagt er als
stimmungsbild aus berchtesgaden dass
viele daneben seufzen ja mein gott jetzt
müssen wir drunter leiden
als ich einige nicht daran halten jetzt
kommt eine andere frage von heike
schmidt
sie schreibt unglaublich und das alles
wegen falsch positiven da frage ich
jetzt sie als experten ist es so dass
viele tests wenn wir jetzt sagen es gibt
soviel neuinfektionen dass da auch viele
falsch positive überhaupt dabei sind das
ist also fehlerhaft ist ja das ist
argumentationen die wir durch die ganze
pandemie immer wieder gehört haben da
wurde uns denn vorgerechnet
gerade als wir relativ wenig infektion
haben dass das ja alles nur falsch
positive sein
nein das ist natürlich nicht der fall es
ist natürlich immer möglich dass mal ein
vereinzelter wert wieder falsch positive
oder auch mal falsch negativ sein kann
die medizinische diagnostik ist auch
nicht zu 100 prozent korrekt aber jetzt
dieses ganze ausbruchsgeschehen einfach
auf falsche positive testergebnisse
abwälzen zu wollen
das ist zu einfach und zu naiv das ist
definitiv nicht der fall also wie
nachdenklich das beispiel berchtesgaden
macht sehen wir an michel dahlhaus der
besorgt schreibt solche maßnahmen
bräuchten wir nun in form eines
landesweiten lockdown ansonsten werden
wir einen wirklich wirklich schwierigen
winter vor uns haben sehen sie das auch
ja man muss immer überlegen wenn wir in
einem landkreis bestimmte maßnahmen
durchführen dann ist natürlich in den
landkreisen drumherum
das leben doch deutlich lockerer und es
verleitet möglicherweise auch den ein
oder anderen dazu zu sagen ja wunderbar
wenn ich bei mir nicht mehr darf dann
mache ich es woanders jetzt haben wir
hier natürlich sehr heftige rigorose
ausgangs beschränkung die sicherlich
auch in diesem hintergrund vor diesem
hintergrund beschlossen worden sind
damit eben nicht 1 1 ein sagen wir mal
corona tourismus stattfindet was ich bei
mir nicht mehr darf mache ich zehn
kilometer weiter dann doch ist es windig
aber gut wenn sich die landkreise die
zumindest zusammenhängend sind in
gewisser weise absprechen dass eben ein
solches ungleichgewicht in dieser
krassen form nicht existiert sondern
dass die maßnahmen da auch relativ
koordiniert sind ob man das gleich
landesweit oder gar bundesweit machen
muss das lassen wir mal dahingestellt
von der signalwirkung her wäre das
natürlich deutlich klar und stärker wenn
sowas
relativ einheitlich kommuniziert und
durchgeführt wird da kommt natürlich
auch wieder so gewisse ängste und
erinnerungen an das frühjahr hervor
ein teilnehmer gesagt hier alpha omega
schreibt das hamstern beginnt schon
wieder ich hasse leere regale
also die nachricht was in berchtesgaden
passiert und was sie sagen ob man das
vielleicht erweitern müsste scheint wohl
gewisse ängste bei einigen wieder
auszulösen eine konkrete frage stellt
giovanni scully sie in welchem
bundesland sind die meisten infizierten
laut robert koch institut ist es noch
den westfalen und danach eben bayern
aber die frage eben auch an sehr stürmer
wir sehen jetzt darf das garden bisher
hatte man immer so gesagt ja das sind
die großstädte da werden die partys
gefeiert
berlin/frankfurt überrascht ich die
ballungsräume wenn man sich das heute
einfach mal anschaut jetzt hat hamburg
heute gerade mal den wert von 50
überschritten die großstadt hamburg und
berchtesgaden ist allerdings der erste
ort in deutschland der sozusagen diese
maßnahmen ergreift kann man da auch gar
nicht mehr reden davon dass es sozusagen
ein großes problem der ballungsräume ist
ja die ballungsräume war natürlich immer
prädestiniert dafür weil dort natürlich
ein ganz anderes angebot an freizeit und
party möglichkeiten stattfindet aber man
sieht doch wieder sehr eindrucksvoll das
eben manchmal wirklich vereinzelte
aktivitäten möglicherweise ausreichen um
ein solches infektionsgeschehen
loszutreten
ein sogenanntes super special event in
dem ein infizierter vielleicht mehrere
20 30 40 jahrhundert menschen infiziert
das kennt man ja durchaus von von saas
koch 2 und dann reicht es eben halt auch
in einen relativ dünn besiedelten
landkreis aus um ein solches
infektionsgeschehen tatsächlich auch
loszutreten und zu einer solchen dynamik
zu führen dann ganz herzlichen dank für
die informationen und für die
einschätzungen dr martin stürmer vielen
vielen dank
sehr gerne ja und das ist unser live
stream gewesen zu der situation im
berchtesgadener land wie gesagt ein
gedenkstein denkt wird
der tag den dieser landkreis heute
erlebt an der spitze in deutschland zu
sein
traurigerweise an der spitze zu sein was
die neue infektionszahlen angeht und
traurigerweise auch der erste landkreis
zu sein der drastische maßnahmen die
ausgeh beschränkungen in drastischer
form eben umsetzen muss ganz herzlichen
dank für ihr interesse für ihre rege
beteiligung schönen abend noch